Can I eat nuts and or strawberries if I'm supposed to be on a low histamine diet?
You know this the question of a low histamine diet comes up a lot because a
A lot of people will we test their cheek swab?
histamine can be a driver of their cancer and
B when we test people's genetics they can have a lot of defects other histamine genes. There's a lot of histamine gene families
So
Okay, then how do I actually live my life on a low histamine diet?
That's pretty difficult to be honest. So it's not about
Eliminating histamines that's impossible. You cannot eliminate histamines. histamines are going to be in your food
so
Then what do I do? So you try to eliminate?
High exposures. I have several good articles on our website on histamine so if you go to
Our website in the search bar start typing histamines and you'll see several good articles with histamine food lists and
About what I'm saying now about how to live on a fairly low histamine diet
Because when you think about histamines, you got to think about a bucket
So you're putting it every time you're consuming histamines or you're causing
Immune reactions in your body that are creating histamines. You're filling up that bucket and you may not
Experience any issues or symptoms until that bucket gets full now granted if you have genetic defects on your histamine genes
You're automatically just carrying around a smaller bucket inside of you
But if you don't have a lot of defects on your histamine genes, you have a normal sized bucket. You can think of it that way
So if you have a lot of defects, you're gonna fill up that bucket more quickly. So
Then how do you fill up that bucket by consumed histamines and by things that could cause inflammation in your body because one of the
one of the
chemicals that are going to be
Produced by your body in a state of inflammation is going to be a histamine
There's multiple
chemicals in that array
Slurry of chemokines that will be produced during inflammatory process in your body, which has happened at all the time, but
The histamines are one of those things
Now if you eat foods that have histamines in it
Together with other foods that are considered low histamines that would help
so
So okay, that's that's have histamines if I get to eat a whole handful of dots or a bowl full of dots
I'm gonna probably I'm gonna fill up that bucket quickly
Save with strawberries. I have a lot of histamines in it
So if I get to eat a whole bowl full of strawberries, I'll fill up that bucket quickly
But if I put some nuts on my salad or a couple of sliced strawberries on my salad, I'll be eating with other foods
They're not going to be absorbed as quickly
I'll pass through my colon, you know, you know without the same expression of
Bucket filling as if I ate them all at once. So it's about spreading things out. That's the key
And knowing, you know, having that list maybe taped up on your fridge and like just being careful with that
That's the whole idea you're trying to be as careful as possible without filling up your bucket too quickly